the Georgia gubernatorial race has been
one the most hotly contested races this
cycle the race has been rocked with
charges of racism and voter suppression
with celebrity and political power
players descending on the Peach State
throughout joining me to react Georgia
Secretary of State Republican candidate
for governor Brian Kemp mr. secretary
thanks for being here tonight this was
how Stacey Abrams responded to your
campaigns charges of hacking your
response let's watch I think he cooked
up the charge because he realizes once
again he has left six million voters
information vulnerable and he recognizes
that if he got caught two days before
the election having exposed so many
Georgians he would lose and so he did
what he does always blame someone else
for his mistake your response well look
I'm you know we got this information
over the weekend immediately called
Homeland Security FBI on the Georgia
Bureau of Investigations
after meeting earlier today the Georgia
Bureau investigations has opened a
criminal investigation into this matter
their cybercrime Center will be
investigating that so it's not in the
hands of my office we have pass
information along to them they believe
it to be credible enough to open a
criminal investigation and that's where
we are right now can you give mr.
secretary can you give us more I really
can't is there one person two people
five people overseas in the country no I
understand look this is a criminal
investigation very serious matter we've
handled this like we always do cyber
incidents in the office of Secretary of
State or any other investigation when
it's criminal we go to the proper
authorities we've done that with the GBI
they found it to be credible enough to
open a criminal investigation and we'll
let them take the lead on that I would
refer questions to them at this point
mr. secretary people from Jimmy Carter
and of course other supporters of Stacey
Abrams have said well you can't be
impartial in dealing with any claims of
voter suppression or challenges to the
the final vote once they're all cast
tomorrow and your response to that has
been well bipartisan
commission is involved in looking any at
any such charges and there's no worries
but do you see why Democrats would be
concerned and if the shoe on the other
foot wouldn't Republicans be saying kind
of the same thing well anybody that
knows how the system in Georgia works
wouldn't be saying that that's a
ridiculous claim it's our County
elections offices and superintendents
that actually hold the election they're
counting the votes their local election
board certifies the elections the press
and the public can go watch that all
this nonsense of voter suppression is
absolutely ridiculous minority
participation is up 23% in the great
state of Georgia there's a million more
people on our voter rolls now than when
I took office I created an online system
where Georgians can register to vote 24
hours a day seven days a week
Stacey Abrams voted against that
legislation and if you look back every
two years these same things these same
type charges have happened from her
liberal groups that are supporting her
extreme agenda she's trying to distract
from the record that she wants people
that are here illegally to vote for her
and be part of the blue wave they even
sued us over that when we called him out
in the lawsuit as to how ridiculous that
was they withdrew the complaint and then
they were suing us to do something that
we already do this is the 11th hour
tactics of them I'm doing my job Laura I
have a duty to keep elections in Georgia
secure accessible and fair and that's
exactly what we're doing well so
President Obama comes into town mr.
secretary
Oprah comes into town and it was all
stout at starpower all the time and they
come in and they could draw huge crowds
are you concerned that that star power
will translate into votes from people
just said well I like President Obama
he's a great person great we liked him
as president and Oprah we love her show
we love the magazine so we're gonna turn
out to vote for Abrams the two historic
african-american success stories are
urging people to make history once again
in the state of Georgia well you know
President Obama didn't win
giorgia I think everybody including
President Trump thinks highly of Oprah
Winfrey but jourdan's are going to vote
for the best person to move their state
forward you know I talked about that
last night at the rally that you know
they had the support of their
celebrities and I have the support of
the president the vice-president coach
Vince Dooley and Herschel Walker the
goal-line stalker and a lot of the great
Georgians I think that's what Jordans
want they want a governor that's going
to build off of us being the number one
state for business in the country six
years of rope in a row that was
announced today by governor deal I'm
proud to have the governor support as
well as former governor sonny Perdue
we've had a great run of a Republican
leadership over the last 16 years I want
to keep that same direction and move it
to a new level
Stacey Abrams wants to take that
completely different raising taxes
having bigger government or radical
Georgians economic over money George's
George's economic revival has been
something to watch and people wanting to
turn that back and say no because the
Oprah came into town I mean god bless
her but you can't you can't argue with
success mr. secretary we'll be watching
very closely tomorrow we really
appreciate your giving us time tonight
very busy night before voters go to the
polls tomorrow thanks so much